Sorry, it sucks after graduation.
It really does.
I mean, I don't know, at least it did for me, but that's the only thing I know.
You just get a bit derailed.
But soon something starts to happen.
Trust me.
A rhythm sets in...
...just like it did after your first few days here.
Just try not to wait until like me, you're 29 before you find it.
And if you are, that's fine too.
Some of us never find it.
But you will.
I promise you.
The world might say you are not allowed to yet.
I waited a long time out in the world...
...before I gave myself permission to fail.
Please, don't even bother asking.
Don't bother telling the world you are ready.
Show it.
Do it.
What did Beckett say?
"Ever tried, ever failed, no matter."
"Try again, fail again, fail better."
Bennington Class of 2012, the world is yours.
Treat everyone kindly and light up the night.
Thank you so much for having me here.